♪ ♪
>> Dana: PRESIDENTIAL BUN
BIDEN IN A FREE FALL AFTER
ANOTHER GRUESOME WEEK.
IT'S A ADMINISTRATION LOCK
RACKING UP LOSSES AFTER HE
PULLED THE TRANSPORTATION MASS
MANDATES FOR THE PLANT AND TITLE
42 TO BE AN EVEN BIGGER SURGE AT
THE BORDER.
MAJOR ELECTION NOW PREDICTING A
SHIFT IN THEIR PREDICTIONS OF
SEVERAL CHANGES TOWARDS THE
G.O.P.
THE G.O.P. IS SOAKING IT UP WITH
THIS HEADLINE.
IT'S BEEN A VERY BAD TWO DAYS
FOR PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
JOB PERFORMANCE IS NOT
INSPIRING.
>> THERE WAS A POLL THAT WAS
DONE A MONTH AGO IN WHICH THE
DEMOCRATS ARE IN CONGRESS THEY
ARE STUNNINGLY UNDERWATER,
THERE'S SIMPLY NOT I BELIEVE
AMONG THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT EQUIPPED TO
HANDLE ANY PROBLEM AT THE
MOMENT.
>> Dana: ETSY TELLING ALLIES
GETTING READY FOR A RUN, SOME IN
THE MEDIA ARE NOW SAYING THEY
WILL WANT TO REPLACE HIM IS NOT
LOOKING PROMISING.
KAMALA HARRIS RIDICULE AFTER
DELIVERING THE SPEECH.
>> I THINK EVERYTHING RECOGNIZES
HOW EXTRAORDINARY IT IS.
WHETHER IT IS SATELLITE THAT
ORBIT THE EARTH, HUMANS THAT
LAND ON THE MOON OR TELESCOPES
THAT PEER INTO THE FURTHEST
REACHES OF THE UNIVERSE.
SPACE IS EXCITING.
>> Dana: WAITING IN THE WINGS
IS BERNIE SANDERS, NOT GOING OUT
FOR ANOTHER RUN FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AS PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN DECIDES
NOT TO RUN FOR REELECTION.
>> Greg: YES, HE'S ALWAYS INTO
SPACE.
SHE'S GOT A LOT OF IT BETWEEN
YOUR EARS.
DOES THAT MEAN?
NO THAT'S MEAN.
[LAUGHS]
SHE'S A SMART LADY BUT SHE TALKS
LIKE WE ASKED HER WHERE BABIES
COME FROM.
[LAUGHS]
AS I COME AT EIGHT THERE'S A
STORED THAT DROPPED YOU OFF ON
MA'AM MOMMY SPORTS.
I GET MEMORIES WHEN SHE'S
TALKING.
THAT IS CALIFORNIA?
YOU KNOWN HIM TO MOVE ON.
SEE HILLARY WAS SUPPOSED TO COME
BACK, BERNIE.
THE DEMOCRATIC BENCH IS THINNER
THAN CHRIS WALLACE'S DEMO REEL
FROM CNN PLUS.
[LAUGHS]
THANKS I JUST NEEDED TO GET THAT
IN THERE.
INFLATION, CRIME, MENTAL HEALTH
IS THE BIGGEST THE BIGGEST
ISSUES OF OUR TIME.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE THE DEMOCRATS
OF KIND OF MADE IT WORSE EVEN
KNOWING THE OUTCOME OF THE LUCAS
CRIME RATES THEY DEFUNDED THE
POLICE AND DEMORALIZE THE
POLICE.
THIS IS APPEARING, HALF A
TRILLION, THAT'S CAN BE ONE
INFLATION POINT RIGHT?
THEY LOOK THE CITY STREETS LOOK
AT SOCIAL MEDIA.
WE HAVE AN EPIDEMIC OF MENTAL
ILLNESS GOING ON AND HE CAN PUT
PEOPLE INTO THERAPY OR TREATMENT
BECAUSE IT'S A VIOLATION OF
THEIR RIGHTS.
SO EVEN I GUESS I'M GETTING AT
IS EVEN IF ONE DEMOCRAT WINS
THAT IS INSANE.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE REPUBLICANS
WHO ACTUALLY CLEAR THE TABLE IF
THAT'S THE RIGHT PHRASE BECAUSE
THOSE METRICS THAT I MENTION ARE
SO IMPORTANT.
THE ONLY THING THAT WILL STOP US
AS IF THE MEDIA DECIDES TO TAKE
THOSE METRICS OFF.
LAPTOP OR CREATE A NEW HOAX
WHICH UP AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE NEXT HOAXES CAN BE
BECAUSE IT CAN BE A BIG ONE.
I DO KNOW WHAT IT IS THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, FLYING PEOPLE, WHAT
IS HE GONNA BE THAT'S GOING TO
ALL REPUBLICANS?
>> Dana: MAYBE IT'LL DO
SOMETHING WITH SPACE COME OUT OF
THIS WORLD.
>> Greg: MAY BE A SATANIC
SECRET CULT.
>> Dana: UNDRESSED UP THE
WHOLE THING ABOUT BERNIE SANDERS
THAT THE MEDICINE AROUND AGAIN.
THEY SAID THAT HIS MEMO ABOUT
BERNIE SANDERS LEAKED.
IT WAS PURPOSELY GIVEN TO THE
MEDIA'S OF STORY WOULD GET OUT
THERE IS THAT BERNIE SANDERS CAN
CONTINUE TO RAISE MONEY DO YOU
THINK THAT BERNIE SANDERS AT 80
YEARS OLD WILL RUN FOR PRESIDENT
IN 2,024?
>> READ AN EXCERPT OF WHICH HAVE
BEEN HERE FOR THE PHONE HERE
YESTERDAY.
[LAUGHS]
BERNIE SANDERS MET WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
NONPROFIT THEN WE GET TO BE
KINGS IN THE NEW TESTAMENT.
HE SAID EXCEPT THAT YOU'VE HAD A
BIG IMPACT ON THE PARTY.
YOU CAN TELL ANYONE WHAT TO DO
THEM BERNIE SANDERS CERTAINLY
HAS A STRONG SET OF OPINIONS.
I THINK HE IS A SERIOUS GUY
SOMETIMES THINGS THAT HIS IDEAS
AREN'T SO SERIOUS.
IF HE WERE TO RUN IF JOE BIDEN
DIDN'T RUN.
I THINK IF JOE BIDEN DIDN'T RUN.
I DO.
I DO THINGS IN A RUN.
IF HE DOESN'T RUN AGAIN THE
DEMOCRATS LOVE A FREE-FOR-ALL.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHERE YOU
ENTER THE PICTURE.
>> TITLE 42, DEMOCRATS ARE ME
OUT.
VERY BRIEFLY.
DO NOT SUSPEND TITLE 42 MONTHS
WE HAVE A REAL PLAN TO DO WITH
THE BORDER.
WE SHOULD DEVELOP A PLAN THAT
DEALS WITH INVESTING AS MANY OF
US ARE SAYING.
AND WE SHOULD FIND WAYS TO
PROTECT THEIR BORDER.
THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
BUT IT'S A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE FIRST AND FOREMOST.
CRIME, WERE KIDDING OURSELVES
WITH THE PARTY IF WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE ALL ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
GUNS, CONCERNED ABOUT REFORM
SEMINARY GREG MENTIONS ON THIS
SHOW VERY OFTEN CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE HERE IN NEW YORK AROUND
MENTAL HEALTH.
THE JUDGE OF SAID MANY TIMES
BEFORE WE HAVE TO PROSECUTE THE
CRIME THAT ON THERE IF WE HAVE
TO.
I'D SAY SOME TO THE REPUBLICANS.
KNOCK THE WIND IS JUMPING ON
DEMOCRATS.
YOU DON'T HAVE BIG IDEAS AND
NOTES ABOUT DEMOCRATS, BIG IDEAS
ABOUT HOW WE GET CITIES TO
CREATE NEW JOBS TO GET THEM OFF
THEIR BEHIND SIN TO GET TO WORK
TO WANT TO INNOVATE.
WHEN I COULD BE THE, ANY PARTY
THAT DOES THAT BEST BREAK I
THINK IT'S THE PRESENTS AND WHEN
THE MAJORITY DID GONNA RETAIN IT
OR WHEN IT IS CLEAR ABOUT ONE
THING.
CRIME IN THE BORDER.
IF WE DON'T DEAL WITH THOSE TWO
ISSUES WE START ON A
DISADVANTAGE.
IN THE FALL.
>> Dana: IT DOESN'T END
INCLUDE THE INFLATION ISSUES.
ON A PLAY FREE OF THE SOUND BITE
FOR YOU TODAY.
AS YOU MENTION TITLE 42 WE HAVE
AND MENTION THE MASS MANDATE.
HERE'S PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
>> TITLE 42 CIRCA ARE YOU
CONSIDERING DELAYING ADDRESSING
TITLE 42?
>> WHEN I'M CAN START
DISCONTINUING HER FROM MY FIRST
OF ALL THIS CAN BE AN APPEAL BY
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
BECAUSE AS A MATTER OF
PRINCIPLE.
WERE IN FACT WE STRONGLY WE
CONCLUDED BY THE SCIENTIST THAT
WE NEED TITLE 42 WE BEEN ABLE TO
DO THAT.
>> MAN BERNIE SANDERS IS LOOKING
PRETTY GOOD RIGHT THERE.
AS FAR AS A CANDIDATE GOES.
>> TRUE, YOU COULDN'T BEAT HIM
THAT'S A RAGS-TO-RICHES STORY,
SO WE HAVE MR. GERIATRIC CAN
CONSIDER THE TWO THINGS THAT IS
PUSHING ON AMERICANS RIGHT NOW.
TITLE 42 SHOULD BE REPEALED IF
YOU BELIEVE THAT THE PANDEMIC IS
OVER, IF YOU BELIEVE THE RESTORE
COUNTRY IS THERE WITH THE
BORDER.
IT'S UNETHICAL TO USE THAT FOR A
PURPOSE OTHER THAN WHAT'S IN
INTENDED FOR AS UP TO
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS TO FIX
OUR IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
AFTER THAT WE PUT ON TOURNIQUET
PROBLEMS.
NOT A BIG FAN OF THAT.
WILL REPUBLICANS WIN BIG?
YES, THEY WILL WIN BIG DOES THAT
MEAN THE WIN 2,024?
I REMEMBER A LOT OF SWINGS ARE
LESS PAST 14 YEARS THAT IN BEAR
FRUIT OF IT THAN THAT IN WHICH
HE OF THE GAVEL AND YOU'RE IN
CHARGE ALSO RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Dana: JUDGE, ONE YOU OPEN
SYDNEY LOOSE.
>> Jeanine: THE TRUTH HERE IS
FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE
THAT PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN IS
WINNING HAD MORE TO DO WITH
DISLIKING DONALD TRUMP I WOULD
SAY THIS.
I THINK AMERICA DISLIKES
JOE BIDEN.
I'M THING AMERICANS DISLIKE
JOE BIDEN BECAUSE THEY ARE FED
UP WITH WHAT HE HAS DONE TO
THEM.
AND IT'S EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC.
EVERYTHING THAT HE HAS DONE IS
BEEN STRUCK DOWN WHETHER IT'S
THE MASS MANDATES, THE VACCINE
MANDATES.
WHETHER IT'S THE FICTIONAL
MORATORIUM.
WHETHER IT'S BLOCKING COMPANIES
FROM VACCINATING THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
EVERYTHING THE GUY TRIED TO DO
IS BEING KNOCKED DOWN THE COURT.
HE STRIKE DOWN THE WHOLE.
AT THE CRIME RATE IS BEYOND WHAT
ANY OF US HAVE SEEN 30 YEARS.
SO I THINK THAT'S CERTAINLY THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE HAVE A PLAN
THEY WILL HAVE A PLAN FOR THE
LAW AND ORDER AND BORDER
SECURITY.
ALSO FOR MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
INDEPENDENT AND THAT WE DO
THINGS TO MAKE THINGS IN AMERICA
THAT WE DON'T SUPPORT OUR
ENEMIES WHEN IT COMES TO MAKING
PRODUCTS FOR AMERICA.
IN THE END I THINK IT'S AS
SIMPLE AS SAYING THIS GUY HAS
BEEN DISASTER, EVERYTHING THAT'S
HAPPENED SINCE HE'S BEEN THE
PRESIDENT IS A MESS.
IN OUR LIVES ARE JUST TERRIBLE.
TALK TO ANYONE.
THEY'RE VERY UNHAPPY.
I'M OF THE WIND UP AND SWING IT
OUT.
IT REALLY IS A SAD COMMENTARY ON
WHAT WE ARE IN THIS COUNTRY.
HE CANNOT LEAVE THAT PARTY
ANYMORE.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY DON'T GET
RID OF HIM IS STUNNING TO ME.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
BERNIE SANDERS MIGHT BE 80 YEARS
OLD, BUT THAT WHOLE THING WITH
HILLARY AND ALL THAT OTHER
STUFF.
MAYBE IT IS HIS TURN.
I MET SIMON I SUPPORT HIM, BUT
AT LEAST HE IS SMART AND HE'S
GOT THE ENERGY AND KNOWS WHAT
HE'S DOING.
>> Greg: HOUSES CAN ASK ABOUT
HIS TIE BECAUSE IT'S DISTURBING
TO ME.
>> IT'S A CLOSE THING, BRINGING
THE WARM WEATHER UP HERE WITH
ME.